[Musique]
quel bel accueil musical plus de 500
fêtards réunis dans un hangar une
ambiance de boîte de nuit en plein
confinement la scène se déroule dans le
14e arrondissement de marseille dans la
forêt de l'automne ce matin est arrivé
une chose que personne n'aurait pu
imaginer au bois de mortefontaine
nouveau talent morte-saison tous les
chasseurs de la peine c'est une
révolution car ce matin un lapin a tué
un chasseur ce matin à la peinture
c'était un lapin qui s'était lapin qui
c'est un peuple qui a vu le fusil
lorsque les policiers arrivent beaucoup
de participants sont aimés chez d'autres
se filme en train de fuir les forces de
l'ordre pendant sa cavale de port tout
près
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vehlmann âmes dans dr marc philippon tac
tac au tac
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est demain que tout envie
vous faites vacciner tout de suite vous
david je pense que c'est un je pense que
c'est une décision très personnelle
personnellement non non non mohammed
aïssaoui oui sophy ouais je suis partagé
mais j'entendais un épi enfin un
chirurgien spécialiste depuis dix cité
une étude anglaise ou allemande qui
disait que si on n'est pas plus de 50%
se faire vacciner
on aurait six à sept confinement jusqu
en faut bien comprendre que ce pays je
pas comment sont les autres mais est
très difficile à gouverner parce que
nous avons dans la tête tout le temps d
attente qui sont complètement
contradictoire on veut être protégés et
on ne veut pas de contrainte
on comprend qu'il faut préserver la
santé de ses proches et de ses grands
parents mais on a tous pris envie de
bouffer la dette de noël si on a une
sale mentalité qui ne nous permet pas
toujours d'affronter dans de bonnes
conditions ce virus
[Musique]
moi c'est comme vous se battre pour pour
qu'une espèce animale ne disparaissent
pas les tigres vont disparaître quoi
qu'il se passe les salles de cinéma sont
voués à disparaître
quoi qu'il se passe elle sait mettre en
pause d'une motion
on lui répond pas là dessus tellement
tôt m
le chrono tourne ne perdez pas de temps
dans la montée je vous rappelle l'enjeu
2 places supplémentaires à gagner
michael on a perdu votre trace et moi
déjà je n'arrive même pas à monter sur
le container seuls les adeptes du yoga
sont capable de péter plus haut que leur
cul près d'agde a évidemment des
pompiers voilà d'autres jouent vous êtes
déjà allé chez sophie oui on a fait
c'est à vous annonce est à vous c'est
pas moi ca ca d'elisabeth lemoine la
femme de l'année en de télé 7 jours rien
que ça et pour fêter ce titre outre cet
hommage à casimir vous avez offert une
pause très naturel sophie davant pour sa
coupe de télécâble la semaine prochaine
l'occasion de mettre un nom et le coût
des potions l'occasion de mettre en
lumière ce soir ce fléau qui ronge le
service public
la quasi-totalité des visages féminins
souffre de torticolis qu elle ce n'est
pas une info qu'une jeune instagram euse
iranienne de 19 ans vient d'être
condamné à 10 ans de prison en réseau
des photos d'elle à qu'elle a postée sur
le réseau social on y découvre le visage
de celle qui voulait ressembler à
angelina jolie il est déformé par la
chirurgie esthétique les autorités
iraniennes l'ont accusé de corruption
des jeunes et de manque de respect elle
espère être graciée pourquoi il sut pas
elle ne supporte pas les petites copines
pâquis ben parce que il leur fait faire
tôt à la maison dès fois j'arrive à soit
en train de lui cirer les chaussures ou
non
ah je les ai rigolé quand j'arrive je
les engueule j'arrive aux univers qu'est
ce que tu fais mais dit je lui nettoie
les chaussures jeudi mais il est pour
mes gilles pourquoi tu fais ça il me dit
oh non mais ça me fait plaisir et
l'arrivée des mamans les cela elle est
en formation surprise
[Musique]
oh mon dieu qu'est-ce qui se passe
il est servi gélade à quoi t'en penses
quoi
je peux pas ôter la réaction la plus
dure que j'ai jamais vu que celui-ci a
réagi comme si c'était normal c'est pas
un truc que je ferai tous les jours des
nuggets des burgers tout ce que tu
préfères
ils se sont servis sur mon corps nu bon
je pouvais pas rêver mieux qu'est ce
qu'on va mettre dans le frigo tout à
leur chéri vient chercher des choses de
nice
c'est un truc de biya oui l'aspirateur
le manger c'est tromper démission non
mais non je veux si tu vis tout seul oui
tu peux tu ne t'attends appartement mais
si tu es avec une copine cct qui nettoie
toi tu lui arrache sa boîte cheveux tu
égoïste et macho je crois que c'est elle
qui avait dit l'égalité entre hommes et
femmes je me demande c'est pas la
capitale l'égalité entre hommes et
femmes ce sera un jour on confiera un
poste important à une femme qui n'en
n'est absolument pas capable bruno est à
la tête de l'un des clubs libertins les
plus courus de la région
et là vous avez donc le camp romain même
avec la meilleure volonté du monde il
doit bien reconnaître que dans son
activité
il n'est pas toujours aisé de respecter
les recommandations du ministère de la
santé
ce qui est compliqué c'est la distance
sociale si vous avez du monde par
exemple si vous avez un gang band une
partouze ou quoi que ce soit c'est
compliqué on imagine bien
[Musique]
évitons
je souhaitais peu
une bonne année bonne santé
en bas tu sais ça va marcher
[Musique]